hey everybody and welcome to the Sha
method here on gamespot.com I'm sha
mcginness this is Chris Waters hey Sean
Chris today we're going to play a little
game called the forest which is a
Sandbox Survival game which may come as
a surprise because that's not exactly a
genre that's totally exploding on Steam
right now so wait you go to a forest and
then you survive using uh items that you
gather and craft uh throughout there can
you believe it that sounds novel and
revolutionary well we're going to do it
as you can see these gentlemen right
here are totally W totally ready to have
fun uh and we're just going to the hell
is that that is some we just no put it
away I don't want to see it that's gross
here we go so the forest uh this is a
game
that I haven't played a ton of it so
we're all kind of we're all going to
share in The Learning Experience played
a couple hours of it yesterday the thing
that seems to separate it from other
sandbox Survival Games is the emphasis
on horror on horror on horror you asked
me onto a horror show live stream well
it's the it's not like overt horror it's
more the fear of the unknown it's not
like when we did the live stream of rust
and we saw that guy's mean dong for like
20 minutes that was pretty horrible that
was overt horror yeah this is like here
you're on a plane with your son oh
adorable yeah adorable um oh so we're
starting from the very beginning you
don't have like an encampment already
made or anything no not yet I wanted to
start from scratch
so game uh tries to give a little bit of
context for your survival you are on a
plane and it's going down and you're
going to crash into the forest thank you
for describing exactly what I'm seeing
on screen
Sean as you can see it's not a very
popular itinerary I'm going to assume
this is like a no one else is on this
plane this is a like a a chartered
flight it's like a Tallahassee to
Cincinnati flight on Air Tran there's
too many seats for it to be that small
it would be two and two otherwise this
is got like three oh my God yeah that's
a this is a thing that's happening
glistening child abducting do you think
I could trade him my child for that copy
of Touch magazine no press X to Jason no
Jason come back oh God no bueno it's no
good Chris you know not Bueno at all I
guarantee that we will find that child
within the space of this 1 hour stream
yeah that's probably true I mean that's
it seems like it seems like this kind of
game would be over that quickly yeah
totally what do you have a Fitbit uh
I've got my little phone here it tells
you your BPM yeah I got a Fitbit I may
be lost in the woods but I still care
care about my physique crit fair enough
are you eating all this stuff or are you
just like putting it into a backpack so
I eating what I need immediately to
survive cuz you wake up kind of like
starving and
destitute uh but as you can see if I
pull open my the inventory screen is
actually really cool because it's not a
menu it's you roll out your little
inventory blanket and you see all this
stuff that you grabbed so like a lot of
little containers of booze from the
plane you're going to got some mixers I
got my pedometer what do you got some
fren Angelico over there some Frangelico
I got the good stuff right here and I've
got a lighter you have a single Med I
have a single Med what oh man there was
a flight attendant carrying axe do you
think that these are like white walkers
that'll come back to life if I don't
murder them well everything is unknown
oh my goodness oh where did that bird
come from bird there was a bird above
me I think my wind up I clipped the
bird well on the plus side now I got
some good quality bird
meat oh look at that oh they died in
sweet loving Embrace oh they couldn't be
together in life but together they are
in death together they shall be holy
crap I cannot believe you just killed
that bird on the back swing what up
iguana
wow ew ew what did you Flay that iguana
yeah I'm going to town on the wildlife
Chris the thing about Landing in Forest
is that you have to establish dominance
you have to let these animals know got
to show them your place in the food
chain yeah exactly otherwise these
animals are going to be all like oh
that's just some regular dude who
crashed on a flight yeah I can I can
mess with him I can like skitter over
his feet or eat eat some lettuce that he
might want to eat they're going to think
I'm Charlie when in reality I'm a Ben
Linus yeah you're a real Linus I'm a I'm
a I'm a Ben Linus I'm the guy who's
manipulating everybody Chris so far you
look like more of a Mr Eko I look I'm
I'm okay with that Mr Ekko is cool yeah
he was cool and also very strong and
maybe he killed some man wow
that from downtown all right how much uh
how much bird me do I have fences oh you
have a I got some raw lizard lizard got
some lizard skin that can increase yeah
wear that put that on definitely going
to wear that put that on oh yeah feeling
real good I got a bunch of rocks I'm
carrying I got five big rocks that I'm
carrying around in my backpack that is
quite a pack so Chris this being a
survival
game the first thing that's a real
threat a kodo dragon can totally mess
you up have you ever seen planet Earth
and when they do the like oh yeah the
nasty like bite you and then just follow
you around for 3 Days yeah you don't
want that you don't want those things
are nasty nasty business so as I said
sandbox Survival game so the very first
thing that you've got to do always chop
down a tree it's a rule of the genre M
yeah it's struck by a lightning spell I
think maybe it's starting to R is that
is that a person over there no it's a
bush or there a bush that this is what
happens when you bring that's a bush
this is what happens when you bring me
along I'm very get immediately freaked
out am very uh Lighty I don't know
scared you're scared I can understand
and appreciate that folks chime in on uh
what you see happening uh in the gam
spot chat just go
oh nice don't stand under that psych TR
and just like that we got you created a
rolling log parade thck log so what I'm
going to create my my shelter is going
to go here that the beach doesn't seem
like a real good place for a shelter but
who am I Beach is I've never survived
for shelter Chris so we're going to set
up these sticks and
rocks oh [__] you get the [__] out of
here oh God where did those guys come
from I was looking at the twitch chat
and did not even get alarm dislike okay
I told you it was a bad place so I think
we haven't really established any sort
of like relationship yet I think they're
still kind of feeling me out for the
moment um later on reckoner here man you
you think I got to establish dominis
well I don't know there's a lot of them
well the first thing I need to do is set
up my shelter because that's what's GNA
give me a save point so I can save my
wow you are very strong dude I'm strong
as hell don't even doubt my strength no
I would never oh man that gave me a GD
optional zero in the twitch chat says
set up on that high spot out on the
beach I should do that huh well I'm
already in too deep it's an hour stream
we're not we're not creating the
ultimate list we can't we can't go back
now I thought there's only forward yeah
just gather some tiny
sticks oh get get to chop in yeah going
to chop the H
actually what it went blue again it went
blue Chris I'm scared I'm scared it was
just some lightning you heard the
Thunder it can't hurt you unless are
there lightning strikes in this game
legitimate question uh not that I know
of
okay okay you've now made a hover tree
and watch as it tumbles gracefully to
the ground
below how many of these logs can you
pick up I don't know like a [__] ton of
logs you sure can oh my God you're
carrying an entire tree's worth of logs
no just two wait oh now I need to get
some more sticks so let's see you need
to get some logs so I need four more
logs and two more sticks the game is
telling you hung you're hungry the game
is telling me I'm hungry yeah you're so
hungry all right I should get some food
then right let's see do I have any food
to eat just yet what if I just slug some
soda that restores energy not
necessarily my hungness I should I eat a
raw lizard
I'll wait I'm going to cook that on a
campfire in just a hot second Bob Jones
says not to make Camp around the plane
that's what I'm saying Bob Jones that's
what I'm saying but Shawn is already
committed to his course I'm way into
this guys I'm In Too Deep I the thing
about the plane is that there's all
those copies of Touch magazine that I
haven't even read yet I want to make
sure that they're easily accessible come
on man it could be skyways it could be
no it's it's Touch magazine it does it
say touch I don't know I'm just making
up names for freaking plain
things uh don't worry Cass says uh the
tribes men check you out for a while
then attack you when you least expect it
so be careful they will come back with
more oh don't worry well I'm going to
come back to them this might have been
an axe an literal axe to
grind ask you a question on my question
is do you want to get chopped over tree
are you D you doing double duty I feel
like you're chopping over two trees at
once I think I am
picked a bad this kind of hubis is just
the kind of thing that's going to get
you into a real dead guy type PL how do
this tree even still structurally sound
so this game is it's a little a little
it's Alpha it's an alpha uh it just came
out on Steam Early Access at the very
end of May so whoa look at those dope
ass logs wow just pretty logs all in a
row yeah looking real good all right
check this out so oh what do you you
guys want a piece of this hey they're
just coming to check I'm take a
nap seem like a good time to nap you
know what I maybe slept too long it's
really dark I'm going to sleep until
morning it really that dark wow it's
really difficult to see what's going on
and I'll sleep another s so I think I
just slept like 18 hours so I'm probably
starving no there's really no better way
to what is that Lantern I don't know
there's really no better way to show
someone that you don't fear them than by
falling asleep in their face yeah that's
really the best way to do it okay yeah
that's a freaky dude with a lantern whoa
whoa okay you're getting you're getting
chewed up this is bad did you just die
maybe I died maybe taking a 18-hour
power nap while the tribes men were
right around me was a bad idea aat says
you're Invincible when you nap but I
don't know if he can be trusted okay
wait you're alive all right so first
time you die you don't die you actually
get kidnapped by the na and you wind up
in this little cave type situation great
great we got let's ourselves a a Tomb
Raider type scenario you can see what is
that a human baby leg it looks like a
human baby leg oh my goodness
weird what the hell is that God what an
the holy hell is that look at it again
look at it again go look go look at it
closer no what it had like six legs oh
wow no doing some weird spider leg thing
quick hide in a chest and fall asleep
power move I don't like anything that's
happening right now Chris what's going
on I don't know man you're being hunted
by some naked spider thing human it's a
human spider situation all right we're
good I'm starving and I'm nearly
dead you know what going to roll the
dice on that raw lizard no that didn't
okay I'm going to wear that put on some
lizard skin and get real Dr I'm going to
get a load on is what I'm going to do
and a sugar buzz and I'm going to slam
these meds wow you are going a whole hog
yeah you are going all right I'm feeling
good yeah you can run now I really
cropped myself up on Boo and sugar are
you climbing out some sort of weird okay
yeah hey this is think I can get serious
Tomb Raider situation all right I think
I'm going to get to the end oh please
tell me that's I'm pretty sure that
follow you here oh the weird sex yeah
you're one person what did you call it
sex demon okay yeah that makes it's
pretty obviously a sex demon yeah all
right I mean on the plus side oh what's
this be too careful Chris oh
God L just explode into limbs why are
you taking them oh God you have a horror
pile now hey Chris yes Sean what does it
look like I'm holding right now a big
lighter
well why are you holding a human skull
you're crotch because I've equipped it
as a weapon oh you going to eat a raw
shark I'm going to beat the [__] out of
this shark with a human head I'm going
to eat a rotting shark you think I can
Harvest get out of here Birds you get
out of here you think this is uh I don't
think you should eat a rotting shark I
feel like I should oh my goodness yeah
chop it up you can't human head a shark
apart this is good meat this is good
shark meat are you even hitting
it you're hitting Birds no I don't think
I can Harvest this you're just going to
end up eating
if I do
drop oh that's weird that's weird okay
so all right we're going to maybe try to
find some food in these bits of I don't
starfish are probably eligible edible
starfish no I don't think they are
everyone in the twitch chat is yelling
Effigy for some reason oh yeah I can
build an effigy we're going to do that
after I get some food because I am
pretty starving right now the only thing
I've had since I got kidnapped was booze
and soda pop you don't know what this
sex demon put down your throat maybe it
fed you no one knows what the sex demon
put down my throat maybe it fed you
something all right so I had some energy
bars but I feel like I need to stock up
a little bit more if I'm going to do
some
exploration oh what up dudes oh man
they're taking your carry-ons oh you
want you want those dud are paging those
dudes are pillaging luggage this is
going to be a [__] serious fight oh
are you going to slap him with someone
else's arm you want a piece of this I'll
give you the whole thing get over here
oh you like this I know your weakness
it's getting beat to death with your
dead friend oh this this arm used to
belong to your buddy Steve and now
you're getting killed with it oh you
want recognize it don't you boom
remember
Steve quit hitting yourself Steve says
right now oh yeah hit him in the No No
genitals what is that about and now I
got to finish the job you are on a you
are on an island full of maniacal
kendalls is that what I'm to be finish
these guys off otherwise you just ax clo
right onto him I don't want to I don't
want them to get rescued cuz they're
still technically alive for the moment
that other dude is just watching you
chop his buddies to death oh yeah you
want a piece of this getting the hell
out of here he doesn't want none you
like this boom oh wow you are go damn
got to make sure he doesn't get rescued
Chris you just axing his crotch
apart I think this guy wants a piece
I'll give him a leg you want a leg I'll
give you this leg come get it oh boom
wow you took one wow you are taking a
few I'm not doing so hot this time hting
you with a head on a stick you should
make one of those just the thing is you
just got to Pummel him with a leg until
he's dead your stamina is
incredible I think can you can you curb
stomp someone when there's no curb and
it's someone else's leg maybe on the
plus side Chris I have more than enough
limbs to build an effigy yeah so that's
what we you could maybe build a weird
sex demon Effigy I could do you think I
should I build a weird sex I mean if you
can it's probably a super effective
version of it right all right so now
that those guys are not here I'm going
to build an effigy right by my Camp you
need to eat the food Tina oh wait your
stomach is full what did you eat I I ate
those energy bars that I found I don't
even remember that happening so eff was
that when you were just horing down tons
of booze should I build a simple Effigy
or a small oh I've got enough for a
small Effigy definitely
this is yeah just put it right out your
window so instead of a nice Bay View you
have a view of some rotting limbs this
is need to grab a couple heads where did
that where did that dude's head go oh is
this another dude still on his body head
hey he found a head oh that's convenient
some sticks and rocks I do need some
sticks and rocks do you think that head
is still here or did I grab all the
heads did I really I don't know those
look like they might be heads oh that's
a head I think there's two heads there
they roll down to the beach thing is
Chris you can never have too many heads
heads are the most rly poly of all body
parts what a bird you need to you are
covered in blood it is suggesting you
wash it off to avoid infection yeah
that's another thing is that you can get
infected if you get too much blood on
you so we're going to take a little dip
in this not at all rotten shark infested
ocean it's fine oh Turtle make some
turtle soup or just Gravely wound the
turtle and let it all right we're doing
good okay got to get some rocks and some
sticks you're all clean and you're only
being mildly washed out to seea by the
tide establish dominance Chris we can't
have these animals thinking they're
better than us oh should I grab the
turtle me yeah get some turtled
stuff come on come on turtle do I have
it get harvested no you just have a
flaccid flade lizard do you think there
you go you got a turtle no wait yeah
okay yeah get is this how I get some
human in there there we go grab a rock I
grabbed a rock a turtle Stone I don't
know check this out is that the
hyperstone that you have pillaged from
Turtle thought I would get those
birds hey you better hold on to that
trusty Rock trying to Bean Birds is
definitely a good way to get ambushed by
a bunch of
psychos all right so what do I need
rocks and sticks I think all right three
rocks two sticks that'll be easy enough
there's hell of that [__] around man
where are all these dead dudes coming
from
listen how do they yeah I don't know
there's a lot of mysteries about these
guys do you think that's something you
find more out more about in the course
of the forest I'm sure that it is
probably do whether or not that's
something that you can find out in this
current version of the game I don't know
I would guess no probably not right
you're an alpha Town yeah I'm in alpat
town you need some rocks get some rocks
get a rock pick up a rock one more rock
[__] Birds this place is infested with
birds this place infested with hover
Birds hover oh [__] wow don't know if my
Effigy did the job go hastily complete
an effigy in front of them to intimidate
the crap out of them or just hide in the
hide in the plane I should maybe wait
until they leave play it cool man all
right just chill out we're going to play
it cool there's no way they can find you
yeah just hide behind that leg it's me a
leg I pose no threat to you don't worry
I am a I am a chopped off
leg oh the the blue flashing thing kind
of gives me case of the Willies you're
feeling pretty jumpy aren't you I'm
feeling a little bit jumpy I mean are I
was doing fine until I saw that sex
demon and that that thing really
burrowed its way into my mind that thing
does not get out all I can think about
is creepy sex demon lady you really it's
it's pretty frightening all right I made
an effigy so I feel like oh you lit it
on fire yeah totally I guess you kind of
have to so do you think that what do you
think this Effigy signals to the
natives uh it signals that you know how
to decapitate people or at least carry
decapitated heads that have been
decapitated for some weird reason can
make another Effigy what you don't have
anywhere near enough rocks for that I
need three more rocks and one more head
which you just had a stick and you stuck
it in the ground there's a head over
here fair enough are you going to knock
it off with a leg going to grab this
rock and then I'll grab this rock and
then this rock wow and then I'll grab
this head get out of here Birds you get
out of here kicking the birds out of the
sky kicking these birds right on out of
the sky switch to my trusty
axe this guy doesn't seem to want to get
split into a million pieces do you think
he's bued stay at it just just stay at
it on his crotch and you'll be fine I
don't think work all right that's fine
can you put like a bird on your fig or
does it just not have the same effect
could probably put a bird on my fig
probably not though that's crazy that's
ridiculous I don't think that'll happen
all right you know what I need some food
cuz I think I might be starving again
yep uh your your stomach has just a big
red X in it uh Fire Let's Make
A
standing fire that seems really
unsafe you already have a standing fire
it's just a fire of human
parts I need one more rock get out of
here bird you get out of here these
birds are all up in your grill birds are
really just can you cook and eat those
birds I should be able to I think all
right where's some rocks at is that a
rock tight grabbing hell of rocks the
thing is Chris you can never have too
many rocks
is that is that like a life motto that's
a life motto and a forest
motto get out of
here you like that birds take that bird
what's the chat saying does the chat
have sound life advice to give me they
do but I just did something weird with
the computer where the chat went away
so I need another head this computer
bites yeah that computer is a real [__]
show Chris I didn't want to say
anything but it's real junky well if I'm
not going to find a head I may as well
get some food oh tennis ball how much
you want to bet I can Bean these birds
with
it split the bird right upright bird
bird
rights see like I'm getting some good
stuff in here this is the worst are you
just trying to use that computer in a
real basic fashion
yeah uh oh I found y here we go fire pit
fire pit to cook food is what optional
zero is literally yelling at you fire
pit to cook food I can still cook food
in a regular fire though no no just
build a just cook some food you are
starving that's true I am starving I
think my health is getting uh you need
to eat something and take a nap all
right all right I need one more stick if
only you hadn't started building that
half ass I can't Sprint cuz I'm starving
just have you been sprinting this whole
time time yeah some Maniac sprinting
around no wonder you're I got hell of
[__] to do look at all these sticks I'm
going to make a dope ass fire do I have
anything to cook oh I have that raw
lizard I can cook that I hope I can cook
it you want to cook your
lizard yes yes all right
now set that on fire with my big lighter
bam and then I'll take this and shall it
on there apply it
yep and uh in a few short minutes we
should have some tasty cooked lizard you
think they're going to come a knocking
they're going to watch lizard legs
probably almost certainly they'll come a
knocking how how do you know when it's
done I think you get the prompt to take
it off oh energy bar I'll leave that
mind I do
cannibalism what do you just have that
energy bar as an appetizer with your
cocktail
hour ahead of lizard Feast yeah all
right cool so I just ate that uh that
lizard and I am feeling pretty
good oh did we lose it oh did we ever
have audio I don't know if we ever had
audio are we not getting
audio all right take a little nap wait
until daytime did you eat the lizard or
what I did eat the lizard yeah oh I
missed it yeah
anticlimax still nice time the leg
is that what people are saying cook the
leg that's what msia is saying seems
like a real poor all right it doesn't
seem to want me to sleep any longer
showi says Ed and zorine when they
played this game on House of Horrors
chopped down trees and had cannibals
fall out of trees oo that seems
fun all
right all right what should we do now
you should drop your Vendetta against
all birds and stop taking a swing at
them but these birds are total jerks
should we go exploring the island ter
not at night time it's morning time
morning is coming I feel like this is
like early early Dawn maybe all right
let's check out what time it is yeah you
need to you need to figure out it is
currently 1508 steps a clock okay and uh
I don't know how that translates I see
it's early morning sun's coming up I
feel like we're good all right listen
let's look in this handy book you have
here I feel like we should make
something good all right so it's got
what you have to learn about berries and
stuff basics of
survival okay yeah you got one of those
a hunting shelter I built one of these
so I think you need to hunt right if you
have a hunting shelter that's a good
point right I could make a fire pit all
I need to do is collect a [__] ton of
rocks your fire situation I feel like
exploring is my best option right now CU
that way I can go find [__] you need a
weapon of some kind yeah I think I do
can you make a a
spear I can find iess you have an a i I
found a spear when I was playing before
you know what we're going to explore
let's go we're going to get off the
beaten Trail and just uh into the wild
blue yonder around see what we find yes
going find a bunch of rocks and sticks I
think find a weird SE this is yeah this
is going to go really well I have a good
feeling about this Chris real good
feeling what could go wrong nothing
literally nothing do I have all right so
I'm embarking on my journey with no food
whatsoever that's fine Sean yes I hate
to break immersion but I think Argentina
just scored with like 2 minutes left in
extra time was it messy I don't know
it's unclear from Googles probably it
was
messy what over here meanwhile back in
the forest back in the forest o there's
a tent
what abandon your puny shelter destroy
all bodies gra this head get that head
you need that head I do need that head
what a sleeping bag and stuff
can you take all this can you sleep here
can you make this your new home forever
oh I grabbed a look it's a poke stick
you got a poke stick oh hell yeah I got
a poke stick this is going to come in
handy should I go back and finish my
Effigy with that head or should I just
keep exploring keep exploring for onward
we we got a forge onward Adventure
awaits that is probably where the sex
demon is don't want to go in there it
was not messy it was anel de Maria what
is that that looks like a head crab
effigy
dislike dislike how do I click dislike
how do i unfollow that that Effigy yeah
just pick up a bunch of sticks can you
become encumbered probably well you can
only carry a certain amount of
everything like I can only carry five
rocks at a time I see and so on dude
this spear is dope as hell feel like you
should Reserve judgment on the spear
until you've speared something yeah you
know that's probably true there's
probably Birds I can
spear bird you want to spear a bird of
course you want to spear a bird well
those birds are [__] they deserve to
get speared such a bird Vendetta it's
cruel anytime I pick up a rock it
automatically swaps my uh spear back to
my default
axe so I'm not wrong the the sun is
coming up right it's getting lighter the
Moon is high I think it's getting
lighter because it's like a full moon
all right well
maybe on the plus side we good getting
some cool [__] out
here so far you've been playing this
game more like the beach the beach you
want me to go Inland I think you might
need to strike Inland all right let's
see I sawd buzzing you let's try to get
some food here first there we go booze
yeah going to get lit
up it's locked are you trying to poke
that open with a stick I think I need my
axe
to open it up what's inside oh I found
fish in there what why was there a fish
inside of that somebody checked fish in
their checked luggage a fish get into a
locked carry-on item like you've never
checked uh halit in your rolling luggage
oh come on you know halit come from
unsustainable harvesting grounds it's
tilapia or GTFO tilapia or
GTFO what about a nice Soul
filet yeah I'm a soul man all right
gonna get a load on because I can't
handle survival Sean is getting drunk
and rifling through people's luggage so
until he finishes playing TSA agent
we're going to go we're going to take a
quick ad break we'll be back in just a
second and see what Bounty he's
found hey everybody we're back still
playing the forest and I understand that
we uh the sound dropped out while we
were playing earlier so I'm currently
actually let's let's vote in the chat do
you guys want me to head back to the
shelter so I can save reload the game
and try to get sound or should we just
carry onward I'll let you guys vote in
the chat let me know how important sound
is to you guys cuz we can try to get it
back if you want it um first 10 votes
count first 10 votes count also there
are some bad guys over here and I think
they emerg from this cave so at least
we're learning cave you know what's in
caves sex demons sex demons yeah got to
watch out for those things as in the for
as in
life all right any votes in the chat yet
uh all right
no audio no audio play carry onward save
we can't hear why are you waving at us
what no carry no sound all right I'd
rather hear yeah seems like the vote is
to not uh
bother going through the menus to like
load it up and okay in that case why
don't we see how this spear does against
those
natives going to sneak up on those jerks
here we go you ready for this oh all
right I'm going to make the sound
effects all right I got
to I got to get a heat on real fast
let's see so I'm starving but I am
pretty buzzed so that's your tummy
rumbling where do you think those guys
went over there right behind you
literally right there oh
boom try it try it try it you want some
of this I'll give you some of this come
get it come get
it oh come back
boom stab stab stab stab stab stab stab
stab stab oh I'm getting murdered way
this guy dead oh I'm dead oh that just
maed you so bad four days well granted
probably 75% of that was me
napping but on the plus side the game
just froze so everybody wins so
everybody all right so including
Argentina we're going to exit to Windows
get some sound going back again let's
load it back
up sounds like we have sound I hear I
hear music I hear all right here we go
is that is that right is that accurate
yeah so I mean I survived a pretty
decent length of time right four days
yeah yeah not too good not too bad not
too great uho great what all right we
need some Pro tips for pro tips from the
chat go let us know we're going to
speedrun the forest in the next 25
minutes of live streaming so just gather
food don't worry about a shelter and
just try to take it to the natives sure
establish dominance full full aggro
establish dominance full aggro first
first things first I have to let this
kid get kidnapped all right which is
fine cuz it's just dead weight anyway oh
don't you hate it when you get on a
plane and they just sit you next to a
random kid and the kid is like sleeping
on your arm yeah he's all like you're my
daddy now and you're like what I don't
even know you kid I'm just trying to
watch uh this thing necklace necklace
yeah yeah it's movie necklace on Air
Tran inlight
entertainment how does a kid how does a
kid take into this he's having a party
he's he's clipping he is getting mean
clip on right now he's clipping right
through the seene he's so distressed
that's a demon child if you ask me he
deserves he deserves to die that kid was
from the back of the plane too and if
loss taught me anything never trust
people from the back of the plane mhm
even though that technically includes me
so there's breathe magazine and there's
Touch magazine so you should breathe and
then touch this guy yeah excuse me my
friend he's going to try to make that
kid one of them although you think so I
bet oh plot twist I bet the kid becomes
the sex demon you think the kid becomes
a sex demon that quick yeah you got to
study for years to become a sex demon
man no kids these days with the internet
and Minecraft they become sex demons
almost immediately wow yeah it's a
different world we live in it's like
you've never even seen an episode of The
Voice youth culture man you are all over
the place youth culture these days yeah
am I right wow what am I what do I even
have equipped a rock oh you can use a
rock as a weapon I feel like I don't
need my
pedometer all right don't drink all the
booze this time all right because
according to optional zero you can make
molotov oh I can oh that probably
requires cloth and booze right
yeah may maybe nope not a demon
not you can't dismember a dead flight
attendant well she's the lucky one I've
crashed in a different part of the
island so let's see get rabbits and
lizards Galore yeah you need to get your
meat on get some Meats going to cook
some lizard first is what I'm going to
do maybe cook some some rabbit too oh
there's camps back here all kinds of
campsites seems like a good thing to
have do I have blood on me oh I got how
did I already get blood on me I don't
know from murdering animals
indiscriminately
probably is that a bad guy that's a
lizard lizard a bad some of these bushes
look their Silhouettes look like bad
guys and I think that's
great because they're just messing with
you they messing with whoa what there's
like a whole tent city over here yeah
what the hell is this about I wasn't
paying attention to you I only know care
about things when I notice them for
myself I learn about the world through
direct observation not from secondhand
reports Sean these are charred bodies
yikes that is wow no good this is is
that a video camera that appears to be a
video camera wow these guys were making
a movie what is this is that an iPad oh
no it's Touch magazine Touch magazine
they probably have an iPad Edition
though touch seems like they would I
mean touch on the touch screen yeah
itself all right so you have lizard
skins you can put on
oh
yeah where where do you put it on is the
real question like obviously part your
body can you look down can you see your
own loins stand in the sun here you
think it's lizard skin jeans is what
I've
got lizard skinn jeans cuz that flight
was on the way to Vegas all right I
think I'm washing off the blood there we
go oranges
eat them you're full don't eat them wait
can you not can you can't pack them in
your all right just eat them just eat
anything so the survival book actually
does have helpful information about what
type of food you can eat so this is
edible stuff here this stuff is toxic so
it'll still give you the eat prompt for
stuff that's toxic oh yeah you just have
to know that the twin black berries are
no good but these guys you can go to
town on those mhm mhm um all right so
not going to bother with a campsite
because we've only got so much time left
however I am going to eat those berries
that I didn't even look at before eating
it's fine nothing could go wrong uh do
you can you craft who look at that
that's not $8 that was a Ben Franklin
I'm eating all kind
whoa am I getting poisoned did you ever
look at your hands man I mean like
really is like all right eat some
mushrooms
cannibal we are going to we're just
going to explore we ain't got no time
for shelters on this show can you wash
yourself off are you still dirty I don't
know I hear sounds do you think it's
birds or do you think it's cannibals
that sounded like birds right we all
know that cannibals make the
sound oh what that was just a rock you
want aqua rock aqua
rock uh that does plus two water damage
but you can't carry any more
rocks there we go that looks like Don't
Mind If I Do any food that looks like a
machete look up what was that no right
there oh it's just a stick damn but
there are batteries oh this is this is
good there good [__] around here that's
a good
rock going to try to light this up a
little wear mud as camo how do I do that
I don't know go roll around in it roll
around in mud go eat mud and then
excrete it through your pores who knows
is that slang for
pooping yes all right let's go hang out
in this mud pit try crafting molotovs
those are good those are blueberries
straight up blueberries that [__] is
delicious yeah those definitely aren't
tber full you are going to eat yourself
full that's fine that's good you need
all your energy for murtilizing
cannibals all right all right so I have
no cloth do you need cloth to make a
Molotov I mean what else am I going to
make it with I don't know look in your
Survival
Handbook uh do you think it's in
traps no new SC Furniture is it
Furniture wood bench go look at the
skull tab on the top top
right oh that is not stuff that's in the
game yet I think but yeah you need Rags
from luggage rags and booze optional
zero is definitely a forest on all right
well I mean there is hell of luggage all
around the island we'll find some of
that [__] first things first I'm going
to go to town on these mushrooms here we
go I'm going to leave I'm going to leave
my lighter running during broad daylight
that seems like an efficient use of
resources this is a power move on my
part it's called letting the natives
know that I can just be wasteful [__] a
lemon oh what come on man you're about
to get scurvy up in here F that lemon
Jesus don't need that it's like you
don't even want to survive when I've got
raw lizard that's all I
need uh where did all this luggage come
from there was no one on the plane well
cuz the plane was you know I'm not
saying how did luggage get distributed
physically during the crash I'm saying
whose luggage is it oh look at that now
we're talking
wait are you just are you come on I got
to remove that yeah you did it fine what
else can I make do you think I can
combine a oh [__] combine that with a
rock and
make oh rock on a stick I made a club
yeah look at that that'll be good do you
think I can
combine money with you can combine Mone
what happens if I combine money with a
rock you can combine money with booze to
make rap video all right I've got a rock
I've got coins and oh I can't combine it
with lizard meat can I combine it with a
leaf no can I combine it with a book no
can I a can I com a all right crafting
fun 's over [__] this [__] oh hey
dudes oh it's time to take that club out
for a spin all right gentlemen
two-handed I understand that You' like
to be my friend
do you want to know how I pierced this
rock with a stick check it out this one
easy trick check out this one weird
trick Molotov time Molotov time oh no
that's all right I'm going to spawn in
their thing and I'm going to Chuck a
Molotov at the sex yeah that's what's
going to happen cuz if there's anything
better than a weird sex demon it's a sex
demon that's on
fire all right feeling pretty good about
this one Chris where is it where is it
think sex demon is you got to find the
sex demon why are we calling it a sex
demon cuz it's very clearly a sex demon
yeah I don't self-evident frankly I'm
embarrassed that you would even ask that
right now so last time I was able to
find my bearings because I had that camp
icon on the map not so much this time I
guess there is some benefits to making
Camp yeah it is I thought you found your
bearings just by sprinting in the
opposite direction of sex demon that's
that that is true oh I'm going to be
disappointed if I don't find sex demon
and then set it on fire I think we all
are going to be disappointed if that
happens man well first things first I'm
going to gobble down some food and get
like kind of halfway load
on have you ever tried surviving in the
woods it's hard to do while sober yeah
no you need to you need to grease the
wheels yeah you need to oh yeah this is
this is it this is where they grow the
babies yeah little baby mud and you know
who tends the babies is the sex demon
sexon is like a farmer what up ter oh
miss oh that was terrible oh where's my
other moloto my goodness did you drink
it Oh no you're the
worst oh good God I had two
Molotov I don't know what happened to
your other
Molotov I felt so good about that one
too survived zero days I survived not a
good amount of days that time oh man wow
yeah tough yeah tough out there Stern
but fair
right go Riot uh commenting on your
performance in that little Skirmish uhuh
airball that was bad that was but the
thing is I crafted two Molotov didn't I
I thought I had a backup you did yeah
you
did all right well on the you equipped
it automatically cuz it went into your
hands according to the Christopher Robin
and neojet Angel I thought that I had to
re-equip all right let's all right well
on the plus side I'm back on the plane
with this creepy kid oh damn it kid I
kind of wish like after you saw this for
the first time you don't have to watch
it again listen every life is a new
horrible life in the forest you need to
immerse yourself in the mindset of an
airline passenger yeah going
down and then waking up not in a Placid
field of bamboo
like Jack but on the beach that's true
like all those Beach people that's true
yeah if you were one of the passengers
from Lost who would you be who would I
be yeah one of the passengers from Lost
yeah H crud I don't know I feel like I
might be a Hurley you'd be a Hurley yeah
except without all the secret
Millions secretly wealthy you don't have
your lottery winnings to torment you no
I
don't I'd be a John Lock John Lock yeah
I would definitely be more of a Jack
than a John Lock like an real Earnest
straightforward kind of guy you would be
on like a journey of re self-discovery
yeah that's why I'm a John lock I'm I'm
out there in the wild to ReDiscover my
ability to
walk all right I've got you want to just
make some Molotov right now yeah why
don't we just go straight to Molotov
Town that's what we're going to do yeah
just go eat those poison
berries what all I see is chairs where's
the
luggage are these twin
berries I'm full I don't need them full
I'm full you are full on an airplane
which is improbable CU They don't serve
food on those things
anymore not on the Air Tran Tallahassee
to Cincinnati
leg get the [__] out of here you are
terrible at throwing things by the way
yeah I think the uh the old Molotov
incident defitely established that what
is that is that the Black Box what do
you need some circuit boards for did I
find the Black Box I would imagine
that's for crafting right I don't know
man do you think that these rabbits are
like agents of the natives do you think
that they start off and tell the natives
where I am I think they're trying to
lead you to safety and you need to
follow them whereever they go I think
that they run in circles yeah that's
that's accurate they're not very smart
they're trying to help you but they
don't they're rabbits they don't know
[__]
sorry sorry rabbits yeah that was kind
of sorry to all the rabbits in the
audience that was a little bit rude what
you said to that rabbit just now yeah oh
that's a medicine Bush that's
good all right do I have enough [__] to
craft a Molotov certainly
do I'll make
that I'll make that I like how you
delicately put this napkin out every
time you roll the blanket that's my
crafting napkin some games have a
crafting bench
this game has a crafting napkin dude I'm
I have a pretty decent amount of Molotov
now you're talking now I'm
talking all right you think I should
make some more no I think you're fine
you got plenty of molotovs you know what
I should make though oh a rabbit ran
across your crafting mat yeah that's one
thing that I make I know man that's that
you got more last time you try to use
that all right going straight to this
guy wow you accident oh look the
lizard's climbing a tree
see it see the lizard on the tree little
target practice see this [__] all right
we're going to get it this time you
missed the lizard oh yeah now we're
talking oh oh no who needs to make a
fire oh no make a barbecue lizard right
on a tree I'll whoa is that it skin
there two lizards I think it skin fell
off oh it reproduced by
mitosis well I mean on the plus side
I've got extra ammo mot to wear oh but
it's AO I thought that would be cooked I
thought that would be cooked tribesman
can climb too as we as we learned all
right well I'm going to make oh
what three molotovs down so I guess when
you unequip the molotov in favor of
something else you don't automatically
stash it back in your bag it's on fire
how could you put it back in your bag oh
man that's disappoint wait no I still
have them
so that was just
incidental that's weird inal Flames yeah
no cuz you missed one throw i h one
throw I CFT four you had five no I had
four all right uh well you know what
[__] this we're going to go find some GD
natives if I don't get them within the
first two I'm dead anyways so let's do
this wow all right natives let's have a
dance
party you're invited and you're invited
dance to this firew walking party firew
walk with me I bet you [__] holes are
right down on this beach aren't you I
don't see them it's very easy to see
things on a beach unless the things
don't appear immediately yeah oh you're
back on Old dead shark beach yeah look
at that guy he's still hanging out still
oh there's a boat you can escape on the
boat no trust me I've tried that before
what it doesn't work what do you get
eaten by a shark no it just the boat is
just there it doesn't do anything you
can't get on the boat you cannot
interact with that boat Chris wow what
do you think this is a beta this is an
alpha
get your [__] together yeah my bad all
right I feel like there's a lot of good
stuff in these suitcases but I'm just
never going to unequip that Molotov no
way once you've equipped it you you're
in Party Town you're committed you are
in Party Town USA so I feel like
this layout is slightly different from
last just go into the woods just go
straight into the woods but I found some
over here last time that is a giant
anchor yeah that's a comically big
anchor wow that's another dead shark
over there where them bad guys at man
this island is
weired oh look you can get a a poking
stick this guy dead that guy looks dead
no I don't need no poking stick when you
have a stick I do have my clubbing stick
yeah which is pretty dope as far as
sticks
go where are the bad guys Chris find
them listen they're afraid of your fire
go to the left up this hill feel like I
saw something weird at the top of it you
think there's like a fort a tree fort
there's a huge tree that's a big mother
effing tree I bet that tree has a secret
door in it you think so I don't
know nope that's just a basic tree a
basic big tree basic tree all right
that's baller tree overstating it all
right understating it one of them it's
let's see those guys came toward me
pretty early last time but do you think
that the fire scares them off I feel
like fire scares them off a little
bit maybe they have some survival
Instinct maybe I'm getting a little
hungry going to Nosh on some of that
tasty a bar bar yeah bar it up I'm going
to Bar it up all right Bad Dudes where
you at you want to you want to have a
little party little fire Party come on
guys see what I've done that never burns
out I've what I've done is I've
displayed the superiority of this
particular survival method which is you
skip over the shelter y you skip over
Building A Fire you just make a Molotov
cocktail and you walk around and
threaten the invisible enemies no one
attacks you nobody attacks you you this
is like the ultimate survival there's
literally no way you can die with this
method it's perfect it's Flawless Sean
you have conquered the forest I mean for
the 5 minutes that we've been trying to
do anything I feel like this has
displayed itself to be the ultimate
survival right go Inland stop this all
this beach nonsense obviously that child
who you have to feel compelled to
retrieve for some reason even though the
paternity test is not in yeah it's
inconclusive yeah you we're going to
have to go into the middle of the island
to find this weird kid all right natives
where y'all at I know you're around here
you made a blood packed with this kid
and you're by go you're you're not going
back on it was the blood packed the fact
that I sired him seven years ago sure oh
well those are twin berries no don't eat
that unless you want to poop so much
that is also a good way to establish
dominance on the island you create a
poop perimeter that the natives cannot
trespass laying down a poop perimeter is
definitely one of the best ways to stake
out your territory but you're on the
Move yeah you're not staying within a
poo perimeter so unless you're going to
projectile poop at them as part of some
sort of distraction technique before you
miss them with the molotov cocktail I
think we can skip the poison berries
where are they Chris why are they hiding
they're over in Autumn land over there
Autumn territory yeah where it's oh
where the ferns are still popping maybe
maybe they can't smell the booze on me
yet maybe they only come after me when I
when they know that I'm a little bit
tipsy and they feel like they have an
advantage they can't smell the serums on
me just
yet if you if you drink like three nips
can you then can you then blow onto the
molotov cocktail and do like a dragon
fire breath attack that would be dope as
hell wouldn't it what's going on where
are the [__] bad guys at I think we
broke the
game you think we beat the island is
this the end state right here yeah that
we expect the credits to roll at any
moment yeah I feel like the sun will
descend from the heavens and he'll say
Dad let's go I don't know man speaking
of descending the sun will descend to
the Horizon at some point that's true
and then it will be night time that is
also true all right go up go up into
them th th Rock situations there's got
to be a cave around here somewhere right
I should I could take the fight to them
they definitely won't be expecting that
where's that where do you think the sex
demon is right now I don't know iside a
cave sex demon sex demon sex demon sex
demon that's just a
stick look at me look at me just walking
around with my bottle of whatever that
is
sake it's sake yeah it's airplane sake
yeah let's see it's a nice
uh dang it forgot what names of sake
types
are regular sake light sake it's a hot
sake cinnamon sake cinnamon
gross that's Fireball Fireball Fireball
is just cinnamon
sake Chris I uh I don't know about this
Sean I believe in you I believe in your
ability to get murdered horribly by a
gang of naked freaks do you think that
look it's that's floating in the water
so
tantalizingly don't go in there your
Molotov is your only defense that's
true what if I just stared off into the
Horizon wow Serene
yeah and to say loudly man this is a
great view I'm going to keep my eyes on
this view I really hope no nobody will
ever sneak up on me here gosh do I feel
secure so apparently combining a stick
with a circuit board doesn't actually do
anything you put a leaf in there man a
leaf yeah obviously no that doesn't work
okay that was a that was a long shot
plug some of
that natives here
natives
Yoo sex demons come here sex demon I
would love like to all right it wants me
to open this okay Basics oh maybe it
doesn't actually spawn enemies on me
until I look at my uh basics of survival
W if enemies come show up in the next
minute then that theory you know will
have some Credence I'll would be
surprised can you roll that Boulder down
onto some natives below that would be
tight as hell pull a piggy from Lord of
the Flies yeah that's mean that's a
that's a literary spoiler sorry guys if
you guys were planning on reading Lord
of the
Flies uh jeez maybe uh you know just
forget what we just said yeah for just
forget what we just said it was pretty
oblique yeah that means what the hell is
a starfish doing on top of a cliff
that's just nature that's just nature
that is the king of all starfish right
there this is a big you need to make
obeses to king of all starfish for
low that starfish has left behind its
watery confines and ascended to the high
EST point of
land I'm wored oh yeah there's something
over there go over there oh look at this
like a Hut oh oh oh yeah now we're
talking now we're talking there's hella
Effigies out front here look at this
yeah you just we're going to find some
dudes come in burning the Flames of
Peace yeah I got who waa that one was
creative that was a good one man that
was a pretty you're whoa oh rabbit
that's just a rabbit that's a defense
rabbit that one spooked me a little bit
what's this
I don't know what that was what do you
think that was a stick a flare a flare
oh my bad
ah all right what are you doing I'm just
lighting some FL you just lit yourself
on fire and then lit a flare and now you
have no molotop a what oh it's all gone
to crap it's all gone to Hell well on
the plus side I do have a rock you have
a lot of rocks and I'm dying so this is
probably a good place to
die it seems like a good place to die
and night time is
coming yeah put the scent put the scent
of blood in the air hey Chris oh gosh
you ever seen somebody poke a dead man
in the butt with a stick no I haven't
Sean that was what happens when you do
that thing that I just said coming on
the Sha method is always such an
enlightening experience it just exposes
me to new and wondrous weird
[__] and Bizarro behaviors oh yeah
lizard I'm I'mma poke the [__] out of
you that lizard is fast you got it you
lost that lizard even go you lost that
lizard that lizard lost you in the
shadows Chris bad news what I think
we're out of enemies I think I conquered
the forest I mean it seems like you beat
the forest I think I beat the forest
yeah there are no weird dudes definitely
no weird dudes coming all up in your
grill you are almost you are very hungry
I am very hungry I'm slowly dying that's
definitely true I mean aren't we all
though we all are we are all slowly
dying when you get right down to it I
think there's really only one option
left and that's ritual suicide y throw
yourself from the cliff all right I
think this is the only thing I can do fa
the well Sean here it goes I beat the
island there's no challenge clearly my
son is never returning to me nope it's
time for R suicide you ready for this
yes these long years we've lived here
will now come to an end maybe if you
jump with your axe out you'll like fall
on it by accident prob true all right
here it goes accident get it this one's
for my lost son I love you
Billy I fell eight feet and
died oh yeah victory over the forest
delightful
gosh well ladies and gentlemen that was
the forest we learned a few things uh
Molotov cocktails uh once you equip them
you cannot unequip them they will drop
right out of your hands yes yeah once
you go Molotov you you commit you never
go back next demons can be found in
caves mhm uh and uh you can poke dead
guys in the butt with a stick and
they'll explode in a little meat bits so
really three important discoveries on
today's episode also [__] Birds straight
up you know what just [__] a bird don't
get me started on birds not even cool
Birds well and with that we come to the
conclusion of yet another episode of the
show I want to thank you all very much
for watching yeah Chris Waters how's the
lobby looking today two hours until the
lobby we're playing some sniper elit
some World of Warcraft Lord Warlords of
dror some other game that's not the US
versus Belgium game but we're going to
be watching it anyways they will be
watching that don't worry and uh it'll
be
fun what Divinity original sin oh yeah
that game looks cool look forward to
that well guys we'll see you next week
until then so
long